the view from a security camera of what
has now been declared a terrorist
incident just before 11 o'clock on
remembrance sunday morning a bomb went
off in a taxi outside liverpool women's
hospital injuring the driver and killing
the male passenger as the taxi
approached the drop-off point at the
hospital an explosion occurred from
within the car this quickly engulfed it
in flames
remarkably the taxi driver escaped from
the cab
he's been treated for his injuries that
he sustained and he's now been released
from hospital as the emergency services
descended on the hospital a major
incident was declared and anti-terror
police moved quickly
the taxi's passenger had been picked up
in rutland avenue in sefton park a mile
away from the explosion armed officers
sealed off the street and say they found
significant items there eight families
have been evacuated from their homes
this afternoon at sefton park a
controlled explosion was heard while
sky's fraser moore was reporting from
the scene
and detonated or ignited they said
by the passenger just heard a loud bang
from the other side of where i'm
standing here not sure what that was
merseyside police later confirmed the
explosion was part of their operation
and said there was no risk to the public
on sunday further north in the
kensington area of the city more streets
were sealed off and four men aged 20 to
29 were arrested under the terrorism act
three on sunday and one on monday
morning
the taxi driver has now been named as
david perry his wife rachel posted
online he is without doubt lucky to be
alive the explosion happened whilst he
was in the car and how he managed to
escape is an utter miracle he certainly
had some guardian angels looking over
him
the police think mr perry's passenger
had built the bomb himself but they
don't know why he went to the women's
hospital or why it detonated when it did
we are of course aware that there are
remembrance events just a short distance
away from the hospital and that the
ignition occurred shortly before 11am
we cannot at this time draw any
connection with this but it is a line of
inquiry which we are pursuing this
investigation is said to be moving at
pace detectives have much to go on mr
perry as an eyewitness and what they
believe to be a crime scene here in
rutland avenue as a result of this
explosion the uk's terror threat level
has been raised from substantial to
severe meaning an attack is now judged
to be highly likely
the police say their work here on the
ground could last for several days
gerard tub sky news liverpool